Damit sind wir wunderbar beim Thema der Sendung wieder angekommen. Diese Zeit mit, was früher war, ist vergessen, die ist jetzt vorbei. Wir nähern uns jetzt einfach der Zeit der permanenten Speicherung von allem. Und so wie wir auf der einen Seite kritisch die Überwachung von allen, wir können gerade aus diesen Gründen auch sehr kritisch sehen, weil das einfach bedeutet, auch das wird nie gelöscht. Und vergesst irgendwie Aufzeichnungen, die nach 24 Stunden gelöscht werden, sie werden nicht gelöscht werden. Im Zweifelsfall. Und genauso ist es natürlich auch mit den eigenen Dingen. Man muss sich eigentlich daran gewöhnen, dass man Stellung bezieht. Und ich denke, dieses ganz offen auch auf die eigenen Sachen Bezug nehmen und das auch erklären und untermauern, sozusagen vorher schon die Erklärung liefern, bevor andere Leute einen danach fragen. Das ist eine Strategie, aber das rettet auch nicht jeden.
Okay, Marc?
Gute Nacht, danke für deinen Anruf. Chaosradio 121, digitale Identität, Leute. Mit Pavel, Tim und Holger.
Sind wir wieder da?
Ich dachte, du hättest gerade berippt gesagt.
Der Chat versucht sich fleißig hier mich zu recherchieren. Gar nicht so einfach. Ein paar offensichtliche Sachen haben sie schon rausgekriegt.
Was denn so?
Aber die richtig dreckigen Details da. Musst du schon in den Chat kommen.
Ich kann nicht mit diesem Wind aus...
Nee, aber wie komm ich denn... Gibt's nicht irgendwie so ein Web... Genau, WebIRC.
So, jetzt poste ich hier erstmal die URL von dem Mix, nachdem du mich auch gerade gefragt hast. Der heißt nämlich lustigerweise CCWC. Das steht tatsächlich für Chaos Computer Club, den sie nämlich so genannt haben, nachdem wir andere Mixer schon mal bei Chaos Radio gespielt haben.
Ja.
Das ist ja auch süß.
Nett, ne? Und dann ist er auch noch gut. Aber gleich ist er vorbei.
In...
5 Minuten. 8 Minuten.
8 Minuten.
Und was machen wir dann?
Dann spielen wir einen schönen Mix.
Und wie heißt der?
Oder das Hacker Lied.
Das Hacker Lied.
Ich glaub, dann spiel ich erstmal das Hacker Lied.
Okay, mal die Idee.
Haben wir den Anrufer?
Achso, nee. Warte mal. Ich muss mich mal gucken. Nee, noch nicht. Doch, da. Entschuldigung. Namen Falk.
Na?
Na Falk, was hast du so beizutragen? Du hast es schon mal ausprobiert mit den virtuellen Identitäten, stimmt's? Und mit Erfolg?
Mit ziemlich viel Erfolg. Der Punkt ist nur, du musst konsistente Lebensläufe bauen. Du musst konsistente Personen aufbauen.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hingehe und sage, okay, ein Anagramm zu Holger Klein ist Kollege Hirn, ich baue mir jetzt eine Identität k.hirn auf, besorge mir k.hirn at googlemail.com.
Ja, wenn du ihm einen entsprechenden Namen gibst, kann das ja funktionieren. K funktioniert vielleicht nicht ganz so gut. Genau, Klaus Hirn. Klaus Hirn ist ein typischer Name, den könnte theoretisch jeder haben. Also das heißt, du kannst nicht behaupten, es wäre ein Name, der nicht existent ist. Und das ist ein wirklich wichtiger Punkt.
Du meinst, der Name muss erst mal plausibel sein?
Der Name muss plausibel sein. Und wenn du richtig fies bist, dann baust du so einen Namen richtig über Wochen auf. Das heißt, du verpasst ihm erst mal ein bisschen Netzidentität. Also lässt ihn in ein paar Foren schreiben, vielleicht gar nicht die düstendinge. Ja, und dann suchst du mal so irgendeinen kleinen Homepage-Baukasten auf und schnitz dem mal schnell eine Seite zusammen mit einem Lebenslauf, den man googeln kann. Also mit so, was weiß ich was, mit einem Abitur an der Schule, die man ergoogeln kann und so.
Also ich hab ja gehört, dass jetzt auch die Suchmaschinen schon versuchen, den Schreibstil zu erkennen.
Erzählte Constanze gestern, dass es Maschinen gibt, die in der Lage sind, rauszufinden, ob du du bist. Anhand deines Wortschatzes. Anhand des Wortschatzes, Satzbau, Fehler oder keine Fehler.
Ja, da muss man natürlich ein bisschen kreativ sein, und sich vielleicht ein bisschen verstellen mal.
Das heißt, wenn man gut schreiben kann, muss man Fehler einbauen, wenn man nicht schreiben kann, muss man alles richtig schreiben?
Ich habe da in Umschlag 2 einen Haken entdeckt.
Darf ich dich fragen, was Sinn und Anlass der Geschichte war? Hast du einfach nur aus Spaß, um es mal zu sehen, wie das ist, oder aus Sicherheitsgründen, oder was?
Na ja, das hat schon mal so eine Zeit lang seine Gründe gehabt. Ich meine, ich mache es heutzutage fast nicht mehr, aber klar, diese Identitäten gibt es noch. Aber das hatte zum Beispiel an der Uni seine Gründe, dass du halt mal mit Leuten vielleicht nicht direkt sprechen wolltest, sondern vielleicht mal ein bisschen eine Instanz dazwischenschalten wolltest, mal einen ganz dummen Studenten meme wolltest, der überhaupt keine Ahnung von irgendwas hat und zufällig mal eine Frage hat.
Du bist Grafenhäut und hast damals die Leute im Forum verarscht. Genau, du bist Tanja. Du hast die Identitäten benutzt, um mit Leuten anders reden zu können, als du selber jetzt redest. Gab es eine Rückmeldung aus dem Netz über diese Identitäten?
Das Lustige ist, solche Identitäten entwickeln natürlich ihr wahnsinniges Eigenleben, wenn du sie zu lange leben lässt. Das heißt, du kommst irgendwann an den Punkt, dass du das Problem hast, dass deine Identität entweder auffliegt, oder, und das ist noch viel, viel schlimmer, wenn Leute anfangen, dieser Identität mindestens zu vertrauen und ihr plötzlich anfangen, Dinge zu erzählen.
Aber dann musst du schon richtig gut sein, oder?
Da musst du schon richtig lange deine Leute pflegen.
Wie lange hast du gebraucht, bis du dahin gekommen bist, dass sie dir vertraut haben?
Eigentlich gar nicht so lange, weil Menschen doch sehr verriertseliger sind, als man glaubt.
Wenn man so reden lässt.
Ja genau. Da kommst du dann schon relativ schnell an Punkte, wo du dann so denkst, da wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Und was hast du mit dem Wissen gemacht?
Weggesmissen, auf gut Deutsch. Was willst du damit machen? Wenn du halbwegs ethisch korrekt bist, dann verwertest du solches Wissen halt nicht. Besonders nur für Zwecke, bei denen du denkst, dass sie angemessen sind.
Kannst du das konkretisieren?
Ja, ich meine, wenn du jetzt durch Zufall was mitkriegst, wo du denkst, das müsste eigentlich komplett anders laufen, dann lässt du halt mal einen Leserbrief von dieser Person schreiben oder so. Das machst du dann schon mal noch. Aber wirklich in persönlichen Beziehungen in einer Form rumzufuschen, das fände ich eine ziemliche Sauerei. Aber das ist eigentlich das, was dann am ehesten verführt.
Und machst du das heute auch noch? Oder bist du jetzt irgendwie auf einer Identität festgegangen?
Also ich hab mich inzwischen auf drei Identitäten festgelegt, aber eine Hauptidentität und das ist meine Reale.
Und schaffst du es dir, dass die auch wirklich getrennt sind? Oder sind die eigentlich nur so Pseudonyme und wer dich kennt, weiß schon Bescheid?
Nee, das sind richtig Getrennte. Also ich weiß, dass du sie nicht kennst.
Also du hast schon mal mit ihnen Kontakt gehabt, aber du kennst sie nicht, Tim.
Also ich weiß, dass Tim schon mal mit einem davon Kontakt hatte, Jan. Na gut, also ich wollte nur sagen, dass es doch auch ein paar Gefahren mit sich bringt, wenn man das zu sehr übertreibt.
Was würdest du den anderen empfehlen, was sie tun oder nicht tun sollten?
Na ja, ihr habt sie eben schon thematisiert. Zum einen ist es so, dass man natürlich selber versuchen kann, die Informationshoheit zu gewinnen, dadurch, dass man mit seinem Klarnamen, mit seinem Realnamen sehr aktiv ist. Dadurch kann man natürlich die Informationshoheit bei Google relativ einfach gewinnen. Wenn man allerdings tatsächlich dann aus irgendeinem Grund man meint, eine Fake Identität zu benutzen, benutzen zu müssen, dann sollte man das möglichst konsequent tun und versuchen, dass diese Person ein möglichst asoziales Wesen ist. Das heißt, man nicht anfängt, irgendwelche sozialen Bindungen aufzubauen. Denn das kann nur nach hinten losgehen.
So klingt sie bei Agenten, die dann auch ihr Doppelleben führen. Und quasi die virtuellen Agenten, die dann für uns...
Und wollten wir nicht alle schon mal Geheimagent sein?
Naja, kennen wir diesen Effekt schon. Ich weiß nicht, ob noch nie jemand von euch passiert ist, dass ihr festgestellt habt, dass ihr euch mit einer virtuellen Identität, mit einer anderen Identität unterhaltet, von der ihr nicht wisst, ob sie virtuell ist, und dann stellt sich heraus, dass sie euer Nachbar ist.
Nee, das ist dir nicht passiert, ne?
Nee, das war nicht der Nachbar, aber jemand anderes.
Nee, also das ist mir noch nicht passiert. Also hoff ich. Zumindest hat noch niemand gesagt, hey, Holgi, Schwachkopf.
Mir fährt ja nur gerade dieses Video ein, was neulich irgendwie rumging, wo dann irgendwie so Bruder und Schwester beide gleichzeitig im Netz surfen und am rumflirten sind und dann irgendwie setzen sie sich irgendwie an den Frühstückstisch, weil sie nach unten gerufen werden und stellen fest, dass sie dieses T-Shirt, was sie da irgendwie so halb in der Kamera angeschnitten gesehen haben, den dann auf einmal gegenüber sitzt. Ja, sowas kann dann schon passieren. Aber bei mir ist das noch nicht passiert.
Wir haben Chaosradio 121. Digitale Identitäten sind unser Thema.
Genau. Und Zeit mal auch nochmal auf unsere Wiki hinzuweisen, weil wir haben nicht nur Anrufer, sondern wir haben auch viele Fragen und Anregungen schon im Vorfeld bekommen. Wie häufig bei Chaosradiosendungen gibt es unter wiki.chaosradio.ccde eine Mitmachseite, da könnt ihr ja schon vorab immer Sachen hinweisen. Da sind wir ein paar ganz gute Sachen. Soll ich da mal blättern?
Ja, blättere mal.
Hier schreibt t.pogue, wir wissen nicht, ob es sich um seine erst, zweit oder dritte Identität handelt.
Was hab ich geschrieben?
Ich glaube in der heutigen Netzwelt ist es schon fast zwingend notwendig, sich eine totale Zweitidentität anzulegen, denn dank Google und Co. kann schon der kleinste Hinweis auf das First Life, die Bemühungen anonymen zu bleiben, dahin sein. Das trifft die Sache schon ganz gut. Dann haben wir hier noch den Hinweis, hab kürzlich einen Bericht über automatische Gesichtserkennung gehört. Wenn das mal gut funktioniert, kann man damit sicherlich nette Dinge anstellen. Klammern Maut für Fußgeger. Ja, das ist nicht so viel konkret mit dem Internet zu tun, aber natürlich hatten wir auch vorhin auch schon mal dieses Überwachungsmoment, das passt dann natürlich auf jeden Fall auch. Kommt dann auch noch mal mit dazu.
Die Musik ist aus.
Lala alle, okay. Dann können wir ja mal eine kurze Pause machen und dann spiel ich jetzt einfach mal das Hackerlied. Was hältst du denn davon?
Ja, da halte ich ganz viel von, falls du es denn schaffst, das Hackerlied einfach mal so anzumachen. Genau, ansonsten können wir einfach so lange mal gar nichts sagen, bis hier diese Lampe Senderausfall angeht. Das ist dein Hackerlied. Nein, das ist nicht mein Hackerlied.
Jetzt quatsch doch nicht immer in die Lieder rein.
Das macht man so beim Radio. Haha, das wird ihnen eine Lehre sein. Wie war das? Was sind Hacker?
Bist du schon wieder ganz dämonisch?
Ich bin dämonisch. Ich bin heute sowieso ganz dämonisch.
Wir sind wertvoll, aber unbequem.
Ich bin wahnsinnig schlecht gelaunt in der letzten Zeit.
Wenn du nicht siehst, dass ich wertvoll bin, dann werd ich unbequem.
Ich find dich eher unbequem. Das find ich aber grad so wertvoll. Gerne.
Sind wir schon wieder auf Sendung?
Wir sind drauf.
So ähnlich. Total drauf.
Außer du. Du bist nicht drauf, du bist breit. Pavel, wie viele Identitäten hast du?
Hm, ich hab mal 5, 6 verschiedene etwa.
Warum? Warum so viele? Also reicht nicht eine, die dich verschleiert?
Nee, damit ich ganz... Also zum Beispiel hab ich eine eigene Slash-Stat-Identität. Dann bei jedem der großen E-Mail-Konglomerate. Also für, ich sag mal, wenn ich irgendwo einen Account brauche. Gut, man könnte auch Einweg-Accounts sicherlich nehmen, aber die stammen halt noch so aus der Zeit. Das heißt, ich hab irgendwie einen bei Microsoft und irgendwie einen bei Yahoo und bei Google. Jeweils halt E-Mail-Adressen, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Beispielsweise ja dann wie gesagt Slash-Stat. Dann gut so mein Blog. Und dann hab ich halt eine berufliche echte Identität. Ansonsten privat zum Beispiel. Also ich stelle grundsätzlich nichts Privates ins Internet. Gar nicht. Also keine Fotos, keine...
Fotos finde ich, gerade Fotos finde ich sehr heikel auch. Ich verstehe auch, das Flicker, das verstehe ich nicht mehr. Was die Leute da veranstalten, das geht über meinen Horizont. So viel Fotos, also auch wirklich privateste Sachen zu veröffentlichen, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Es gab vor ein paar Wochen einen schönen Bericht, den du auch verlinkt hast beim Haar II der Tag. Großartige Sendung, die es auch als Podcast gibt über Privatsphäre und so. Da war der Anlass, diese Mikado-Geschichte, auf die wir eigentlich auch nochmal drauf eingehen sollten. Jetzt habe ich den Faden verloren. Was hast du gerade gesagt?
Ich kann nicht nachvollziehen, warum die Leute so viele Fotos, auf denen auch eindeutige Sachen erkennen.
Ein Interviewpartner meinte, mit der Ankunft des Handys ist den Leuten einfach die Privatsphäre irgendwie abhanden gekommen. Weil man jeden Morgen im Zug zur Arbeit in so viele Geschichten von anderen Leuten eingetaucht wird, dass einem auch die eigene Privatsphäre dann irgendwo entglitten ist. Vielleicht gar nicht mal so im negativen Sinne, dass man sich einfach daran gewöhnt hat, dass man alles in einer Öffentlichkeit miteinander teilt. Und in gewisser Hinsicht macht das natürlich auch Spaß, weil Tagebuchschreiben hat man schon immer gemacht, jetzt macht man es halt öffentlich. Und Fotos tauschen die ja abends. Es gab schon immer so diesen Drang von Leuten eben zu zeigen. Und man zeigt jetzt halt einfach auf dem Netz, dass das eben dieses Abfallprodukt hat, dass eben sehr viel mehr Leute als es vielleicht interessieren sollte, das sehen können und dass das negative Auswirkungen hat. Das wird halt nicht so, das ist halt nicht das Erste, worüber die Leute nachdenken. Und diese Grundhaltung findet man natürlich in jeder Diskussion. Dieses ich hab nichts zu verbergen, ich hab nichts zu befürchten, ich mach ja nichts Böses und so.
Ich bin ja anständig, mir muss man keinen Trojaner schicken.
Ja, was für die meisten auch gilt. Nur diese ganzen Nebeneffekte, die jetzt eben mit dazu kommen, sehen natürlich die Leute. Ist ja auch klar, weil es technisch komplex ist. Aber das heißt nicht, dass es das nicht gibt und dass man darüber nicht nachdenken sollte.
Achso, was ich vielleicht noch hinzufügen, was ich sonst tue, ist, ich hab halt Betreiber eigene Server. Also wenn ich irgendwo Sachen beispielsweise für Freunde, Passwort geschützt oder für Bekannte veröffentliche, dann hoste ich die aber auf meinen eigenen Servern. So weit geht auch mein Vertrauen nicht, dass ich irgendeinem Anbieter auch nur trauen würde, dass er halt mit meinen Daten irgendwo die wirklich unter Verschluss hält und die nicht wegkommen.
Dein Blog liegt auf einem Server, der in deiner Wohnung steht. Das heißt, du würdest noch nicht mal irgendwie einen Feldwald- und Wiesenprovider, der so ein bisschen Hosting betreibt.
Also beim öffentlichen Blog ist es relativ egal, aber ich hab halt auch für bestimmte Projekte einfach Blogs oder Wikis aufgesetzt für geschlossene Benutzergruppen. Und die sitzen bei mir auf meinem Server. Gut, ich würde auch irgendwo einen gehosteten Meet-Server oder so. Das wäre auch noch in Ordnung, solange ich halt die Maschine unter Kontrolle habe, solange ich dort Rute habe und weiß, das ist mein Gerät und nur ich hab die Verfügungsgewalt darüber. Nur ich kann da drauf und hab verschlüsselte Platten, sodass selbst wenn das physikalisch entwendet wird, niemand was damit anfangen kann.
Was empfiehlst du jetzt mir? Also ich kann überall Rute haben, ich wüsste noch nicht, was damit anzufangen. Ich wollte nur kurz anmerken, dass ich es geschafft habe, jetzt über ein Web Chat Interface, Interface, sagt man Interface.
Ja, ein webbasiertes.
Ja, den ich beweisen soll, dass ich wirklich holger bin. Bin ich?
Sag mal, sag mal, sag mal. Was denn? Na tipp mal. Nix kommt.
Diese Tastatur ist eine solche Katastrophe auch hier.
Jetzt kam aus dem Chat, wir müssen noch mal sagen, wo der Chat ist. Der Chat liegt auf dem IRC-Server, irc.reenote.net, natürlich Lattenzaun Chaos Radio. Da könnt ihr mit quatschen. Hier gibt's dann auch immer gleich die Links zu den Sachen, die wir erwähnen, die wir selber reintippen müssen.
Tim Pridloff hat Menstruationsbeschwerden. Ist das in Ordnung? Ich wusste, dass das in Ordnung ist.
Du bleibst halt immer bei der Wache. Wo sind die frischen Gedanken, die neue Musik und die besten Schreiber? Einer kann es dir sagen, Johnny Häusler auf Trackback. Hier bei Fritz. Und leg mal auch dabei, Tony Maoni aus dem Freisein. René Holl.
Trackback, die Show mit Spreeblick.
Aus der weiten, wunderlichen Welt der Blogs, Podcasts und kostenlosen Downloads.
Mehr Infos fritz.de.
Trackback, immer samstags ab 18 Uhr.
Und das hört man um eine nachher zwölf. Mit Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
In Italien hat die Mitte-Links-Regierung von Ministerpräsident Brodi die Vertrauensabstimmung im Senat gewonnen. Die Senatoren votiert mit 162 gegen 157 Stimmen für den Regierungschef. Da er in der Abgeordnetenkammer über eine klare Mehrheit verfügt, kann er mit seiner Mitte-Links-Koalition weiterregieren. Staatspräsident Napolitano hatte Brodi nach seinem Rücktrittsgesuch aufgefordert, nochmals einen Neuanfang zu versuchen. Aus Protest gegen den geplanten Stellenabbau bei Airbus haben Beschäftigte in Deutschland und Frankreich heute Abend, nee, heute tagsüber auch schon, ihre Arbeit niedergelegt. In den Werken Pharell, Norden, Hammond, Laubheim in Deutschland soll die Arbeit nach Angaben der EG Metall vor Freitag nicht wieder aufgenommen werden. Airbus hatte heute angekündigt, in den nächsten vier Jahren 10.000 Stellen zu streichen, 3.700 davon in Deutschland. Der Bayer Sharing-Konzern will an seinem Hauptsitz in Berlin knapp 1.000 Stellen abbauen. Das bestätigte der Vorstand von Bayer in Berlin. Bis Mitte 2008 soll er aber auf betriebsbedingte Kündigungen verzichtet werden. Für 350 Mitarbeiter seien bereits individuelle Lösungen wie Ruhestandsregelungen, Altersteilzeit oder Abfindungen gefunden worden. In Deutschland haben derzeit etwa 1, 3 Millionen junge Menschen keinen Berufsabschluss, das sagte Bundesbildungsministerin Schavan nach einem Treffen der Kultusminister in Berlin. Betroffen seien fast 15% aller 20- bis 29-Jährigen. Viele von ihnen haben einen Migrationshintergrund und keinen Schulabschluss. Bund und Länder wollten dieses Problem künftig Hand in Hand angehen, sagte Schavan. Zum Beispiel mit frühkindlicher Förderung, um Sprachprobleme schon zu beheben, bevor die Kinder eingeschult werden. Etta Bessey ist im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals ausgeschieden, die Berliner verloren beim VfB Stuttgart mit 2 zu 0. Viele Wolken und Regen heute Nacht. Allerdings soll der Regen langsam abflauen. Die Temperatur sinkt auf 7 bis 4 Grad. Morgen allerdings weiterhin insgesamt wolkig und regnerisch. Etwas Sonne vielleicht bei maximal 10 Grad. Der Verkehr wird mit einer Meldung A2 Berliner Ring Richtung Magdeburg. Vorsicht bitte zwischen Brandenburg an der Havel und Vorlin. Hier könnten noch Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn liegen. Ansonsten gute Fahrt.
Danke Gary, 4,512.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1? Dann Fritz im Raum Allermünde.
Chaosradio 121 ist hier digitale Identität in unser Thema und der Chat hat eben gesagt, das ist super so ein Chat. Fritz Jingles sind manchmal ganz lustig, stand da oder so was ähnliches. Manchmal. Ja es gibt so eins, das dürfen wir eigentlich nicht spielen, weil der Chef gesagt hat, ey Jungs das ist so far out, das können wir den Leuten nicht zumuten. Die schalten ab. Heutzutage will Radio ja Abschaltimpulse vermeiden.
Aber wir sind ja beim Chaosradio.
Genau und darum, wir sind ja der Abschaltimpuls. Wir, wir brauchen so T-Shirts, wir sind der Abschaltimpuls. Das Jingle, das tagsüber nie im Radio läuft.
Oh die Nasszelle ist trocken.
Achtung, Achtung, hier spricht die Fritz-Zentrale. Die Fritz-Brahma-Shatva-Vachi-Pura-Yoga-Gruppe trifft sich in fünf Minuten im Raum 317 direkt neben der Besenkammer.
Oh nein, und ich hab meinen Helm gegessen.
Und das hört man.
Habe ich zufällig hier auf dem Server gefunden.
Im Experimental-Orner.
Ich würde sagen, es ist echt zeitlos.
Ja, muss ich mal machen. Macht ihr mal Sendung.
Ich brate mal hier was.
Ach so. Wir sollen Sendung machen.
Ach so. Ja, hallo. Willkommen. Hier ist, wie heißt doch gleich der Sender?
Fritz.
Und wir sind das Chaos Radio. Das Thema ist digitale Identitäten und wir haben schon über einiges geredet, aber über Technik nicht so viel. Und da du gerade mit Technik aufgehört hast, dachte ich mir, können wir doch gleich mal weiter machen. Du sprachst nämlich über die Kontrolle über die eigene Identität, nein, über die eigene Infrastruktur haben. Das ist natürlich schon mal eine gute Sache, da gibt es einige Aspekte, zum Beispiel so dieses Zensieren von großen Sites.
Genau, wenn ich...
Noch mal ein Beispiel, hier in Russland geht es gerade ganz übel ab, weil die Blogosphäre, da die normale Medienlandschaft schon weitgehend gleichgeschaltet ist in Russland derzeit, ist die Blogosphäre derzeit der aktivste Bereich.
Weil die Russen sind irgendwie skrupellos, was das Internet angeht.
Jaja, die Russen sind ganz gnadenlos, die haben jetzt auch sich den russischen Ableger von Live Journal, also livejournal.ru, irgendwie geschnappt gekauft worden von so einer russischen Firma, die dann auch gleich staatstragend dahergegangen ist und komplette Beiträge entfernt hat, Kommentare entfernt hat, ganze Blogs gesperrt hat. Und so geht es halt auch ab. Und das Problem ist natürlich in dem Moment, wo man auf irgendwas postet, wo man nicht selber die Kontrolle darüber hat, dann ist man da ausgeliefert. Das ist natürlich bei so was wie Foren und so, wo man es zentral trifft, nicht so einfach. Wir hatten früher das Zensurproblem schon ganz am Anfang. Da gab es eigentlich was viel besseres als Webforen. Ich bin ja immer noch, also ich mach ja auch nicht alles mit mir und da stellen ja zwar immer alle, das wäre so, aber es gibt so zwei Sachen, die finde ich echt furchtbar. Und das eine sind Webforen und das andere ist Second Life. Über Second Life will ich nicht reden, finde ich wirklich sinnlos. Aber Webforen finde ich irgendwie noch schlimmer, weil das ist irgendwie der Versuch, alles das noch mal neu zu erfinden, was das Usenit damals schon wunderbar gemacht hat, bloß schlechter, also vollkommen unbenutzbar.
Wobei, da konnte man diese Heisekommentatoren links noch abwatschen im Usenit.
Heiseforum ist noch mal eine Stufe tiefer, also sowohl technisch wie diese Webseite funktioniert, das ist so unterirdisch und ich glaube, das hat da noch eine direkte Auswirkung auf den Inhalt, aber darüber wollte ich ja gar nicht reden. Ich finde es einfach nur extrem unpraktisch. Worüber wollte ich eigentlich reden? Ich wollte darüber reden, über technische Infrastruktur. Im Bereich Identität ist das natürlich jetzt gerade ein echtes Thema. Durch diese ganzen Web 2.0 Websites einfach Login, Password, Login, Password. Die Leute wissen schon gar nicht mehr, damit umzugehen. Also nur wenn man so halbwegs versiert ist, dann kann man mit so was umgehen wie mit einer Keytrain. Bei Mac gibt es das ja schon lange und bei Windows gibt es eine ganze Menge Lösungen, die das ähnlich machen. Also ein Programm, was quasi für einen die Passwörter sich merkt, in dem Moment, wo man sie neu eingegeben hat. So dass wenn man auf eine Webseite wieder draufkommt, dass es eben automatisch ausgefüllt wird. Das bringt das so ein bisschen in den Griff, aber wenn man mit wechselnden Rechnern arbeitet, man tendiert einfach dazu, immer dasselbe Passwort zu nehmen. Mit dem Problem, dass wenn irgendeine Webseite mal wieder aufgemacht wurde, was weiß ich hier, Studi4Z, die werden ja alle drei Monate glaube ich einmal durchgeschüttelt und ausgeleert. Und dann ist halt das Passwort weg. Und üblicherweise können die Leute dann immer die Finger nicht davon lassen und dann probieren sie halt erst mal aus, dieselben Accounts auf anderen Webseiten mit demselben Passwort zu machen. Und da klappt es dann halt eben auch häufig. Um diesem Problem dann was entgegenzusetzen, scheinen sich jetzt gerade alle auf so einen neuen Standard zu einigen. Da muss man erst mal gucken, wie gut das funktioniert. Er heißt Open ID. Das heißt, das wird man wahrscheinlich demnächst ein bisschen häufiger sehen. Auch Wikipedia hat angekündigt, dass sie das unterstützen wollen. Und Open ID ist in gewisser Hinsicht erst mal ein positiver Schritt, da es bedeutet, dass man seine Identitätsüberprüfung jetzt auch selbst in die Hand nehmen kann. Also was steckt dahinter?
Ja, es ist ja nicht der erste Versuch, also Microsoft wollte ja mit Passport, Microsoft Passport so ein Single Sign-on Service machen. Alle anderen großen eigentlich auch, aber das ist halt dann immer daran gescheitert, dass eigentlich niemand sich seine Benutzer von Microsoft oder sonst wem irgendwo verwalten lassen konnte. Und plötzlich dann keine Ahnung, Microsoft sich entscheidet, einem vielleicht die ganze Nutzerbasis unter dem Hintern wegzuziehen. Also es war klar, so ein Single Sign-on im Internet funktioniert nur dann, wenn er ja offen und verteilt ist.
Wenn alle gleichzeitig auch dann teilhaben können und selber Dienst anbieten können.
Und das leistet Open ID.
Das behauptet Open ID, das zu leisten, das muss ich jetzt erstmal bewähren. Aber vom Konzept her ist es schon mal ein wichtiger Ansatz.
Ja, vom Konzept her könnte ich dann zum Beispiel auch hingehen und zu Hause mir auch eben einen entsprechenden Open ID Server hinstellen, der dann die Authentifizierung im Prinzip gegenüber allen Diensten, die ich nutze, dann die Open ID fähig sind, dann übernimmt. Oder ich könnte halt auch wiederum dritte wie, wer hat es im Moment am Start noch, wer bietet da Authentifizierungsdienste an? Yahoo, glaube ich, war.
Und AOL. Die haben es schon am laufen. Genau, ist alles noch so ein bisschen besser. Hast du schon verstanden, worum es geht, Heugi? Oder war das gerade schon?
Nee, nee, nee, das geht schon.
Einmal registrieren und dann überall theoretisch.
Ich habe 100 Passworter zu 100 verschiedenen Seiten auf einem einzigen Server liegen und zudem habe ich einen Schlüssel.
Nee, es läuft anders. Also anstatt dass du sagst, ich bin Heugi234 und mein Passwort ist Hatschi, gehst du hin und sagst, ich bin... Hast du irgendwie ein eigenes Domain? Sag mal, hast du ein eigenes Domain? Stackenbrochen.de Stackenbrochen.de, genau. Dann sagst du irgendwie, ich bin Heugi.stackenbrochen.de Das war's dann schon. Und das war's dann. Dann sagst du, zack, return. Und dann diese Webseite, wo du das eingegeben hast, was auch immer das ist, nehmen wir jetzt mal Wikipedia, das ist da jetzt noch nicht eingebaut, aber it's coming soon. Dann fragt diese Webseite, also die Wikipedia Webseite, fragt dann den Server, der sich hinter dieser Domain versteckt, also holgi-stangenbaum.de, hallo, du hast du irgendwelche Informationen bezüglich Identifizierung für mich. Und dann sagt er, ja, hier, irgendwie klick doch mal da. Und dann klickt er da. Und dann gibt's halt mehrere Methoden. Es gibt so ein komplett im Hintergrund ablaufende automatische Geschichte, die sieht man dann gar nicht. Dann ist man einfach so magisch angemeldet. Aber was jetzt wahrscheinlich in der ersten Schritt häufiger sein wird, ist, dass dann sozusagen deine Webseite übernimmt und du dich bei deinem eigenen Server einloggst und sagst, hallo, ich bin's wieder. Und da tippst du dein eines Passwort ein und dann sagt dein Server, diese anderen Webseite, also Holger hat sich hier korrekt angemeldet. Du darfst mir jetzt glauben, dass der jetzt auch wirklich am Bildschirm sitzt. Und damit hast du sozusagen nur noch ein Passwort für alle. Und bist halt überall derselbe. Du bist halt immer Holger, Stachentorchen.de. Wenn du einmal dein Passwort änderst, dann änderst du es quasi für alle. Aber du hast nicht 1000 Passwörter, sondern nur noch ein Passwort für einen Identitätsserver.
Und du kannst es sogar auf deinem eigenen Server speichern. Du musst es nirgendwo dann rausgeben.
Ich hab doch keinen eigenen Server.
Dann kannst du zu irgendeinem Identity Provider, die jetzt demnächst aus dem Boden schießen werden, gehen. Oder du nimmst vielleicht auch Google. Oder du nimmst halt auch Yahoo als dein Identity Provider mit deiner Yahoo Identity. Da geht das dann halt im Prinzip weiter. Derzeit erschließt dir Yahoo sozusagen nur die Dienste von Yahoo. Aber demnächst könnte es sein, dass deine Yahoo Identität dir auch alle anderen Sachen, das Kommentieren auf meinem Blog oder sowas, erschließt.
Oder du suchst dir irgendwie eine NGO deines Vertrauens, die dann vielleicht ähnliche Dienste anbietet. Keine Ahnung. Greenpeace, CCC.
OpenID.CCC.de. Nö, gibt's noch nicht. Muss mal diskutieren.
Okay Wir telefonieren noch eine Runde. Lang in der Leitung gehängt, gehandgehängt, hallo Ende. Wie viele Identitäten hast du?
Ja, das ist bei mir eigentlich ein ziemliches Problem. Ich hab genau eine Identität.
Und das ist die, die du hast? Also ist die auch auf deine Person auch zurückführbar oder ist das eine, die sowieso schon komplett zurückführt?
Auf jeden Fall auf meine Person zurückführt. Das hab ich mir halt damals so gemacht, als ich jung und frisch war. Und da wollte ich halt ganz bewusst, dass mich die Leute halt wiedererkennen. Aber mittlerweile ist es halt schon ein bisschen problematisch.
Also du bereust einige Dinge, die du so...
Ja, könnte man so sagen. Also es ist halt so, wenn man 15, 16 Jungen schreibt, dann ist das halt noch ein bisschen naiv und merkwürdig.
Aber könnte Andy nicht hingehen und sich selbst noch mal erklären? Also einfach sich selbst zitieren und sagen, meine Fresse hab ich damals einen Scheiß geschrieben, heute seh ich das ganz anders. Weil das dokumentiert das Netz ja dann auch.
Also mittlerweile hab ich auch geschafft, dass unter dem, also wenn man meinen Namen bei Google eingibt, auch wirklich meine Adresse und meine Homepage ist. Sodass ich da, sag ich mal, noch ein bisschen was richtig stellen kann. Aber wenn man das halt nicht schafft, dann ist man natürlich bei einem späteren Arbeitgeber oder so. Also ich mach im Moment noch mein Abitur. Beim späteren Arbeitgeber hat man dann natürlich das Problem, dass der einmal bei Google eingibt und dann sieht er halt, was macht der denn da so? Was hat der denn so für Interessen? Schon ziemlich problematisch. Ich wollte auch noch mal sagen, das Problem ist, finde ich auch, dass man sich ja wirklich in jedem Forum oder bei jedem Dienst, den man nutzen möchte, explizit anmelden muss, um überhaupt die kleinsten Sachen zu machen. Also in einem Forum zum Beispiel wirklich nur um die Suche zu benutzen. Also ich finde, das ist ein Unding, warum man sich anmelden muss, nur weil man die Suche benutzen kann.
Das hängt so ein bisschen vom Forum ab. Häufig ist es halt so, Webseiten und Dienste und Informationsangebote werden einfach aus einem einzigen Grund bereitgestellt, um eine Community aufzubauen und Daten zu sammeln, weil das hat einfach einen gewissen Wert. Und in dem Moment, wo man sozusagen daran teilnehmen will, man wird gezwungen sich anzumelden, dann ist man dann eben in die Falle gegangen. Das muss jetzt nicht immer so einen negativen Touch haben, wie ich jetzt vielleicht gerade eine Stimme hatte, aber natürlich ist das auch ein Ziel dabei.
Ja, also ich finde, wie die Wikipedia das macht, ist eigentlich das Sinnvollste, dass das Anmelden eine Option ist. Wie gesagt, ich sehe das auch so, dass das saugt.
Wobei auch die Wikipedia das eingeschränkt hat. Nach der ersten aufbrausenden politischen Diskussion in den USA ist es jetzt so, dass du keinen neuen Artikel mehr anlegen kannst, ohne eingeloggt zu sein.
Das kann zwar nachher verändern, aber wie oft legst du einen neuen Artikel an?
Dann seltener halt, weil ich muss mich halt anmelden. Und bisher hat die Wikidion, also es war ja kein Grund, dass sie gesagt haben, unser Wiki funktioniert nicht mehr, sondern es war eher so eine Reaktion auf diese Vorfälle mit geänderten Biografien und so. Na gut, vielleicht heißt das auch, dass das Wiki nicht funktioniert.
Also ich hab auch noch die Erfahrung gemacht, bei Google gibt es ja auch seit neuestem so einen tollen Dienst. Das nennt sich ja dieses SketchUp, dieses Programm, mit dem man bei Google Earth 3D-Gebäude malen kann. Genau, und 3D-Gebäude machen kann. Und da hab ich halt einfach mal ausprobiert vor ein paar Monaten oder so. Hab da halt einfach mal mein Haus so aber wirklich grob modelliert. Also total hässlich, einfach nur mal 5 Minuten drangesetzt und hab's gemacht. Ja und dann zwei Monate später natürlich gibt man seinen Namen ein. Und man findet dieses wirklich peinliche Modell.
Weil du den da reingeschrieben hast als Auto?
Ja natürlich, ich hab da, weiss nicht, ich wollte halt einfach nur sehen, ob das dann auch irgendwie in Google Earth erscheint.
Was macht Google eigentlich, was macht Google mit Docs and Spreadsheets, diesem Dienst XLS und Doc-Dateien online darzustellen? Kannst du hochladen, also wenn du gerade mal kein Microsoft-Produkt da hast und du trotzdem ein Excel-Spreadsheet angucken willst, kannst du das da hochladen und lesen die das eigentlich auch aus? Die Inhalte des Spreadsheets, was du da hochschiebst?
Was meinst du mit auslesen?
Naja, sie lesen ja meine Mail aus. Also sie lesen automatisiert mit.
Naja, lesen mit klingt immer so, als würde jemand auf den vollständigen Inhalt abgestellt sein. Es geht ja eher um die Anpassung an die Werbung. Und natürlich generell das Auswerten von Worten. Google weiß immer, was der Trend ist. Das haben sie alle schon in ihrer Datenbank liegen.
Also ich würde da Google gar nicht anders sehen als andere, ich sag mal ASP-Dienste, so hieß das, von ein paar Jahren, wo man auch gedacht hat, gut, wir lagern alle unsere Daten im Netz und greifen nur noch per Browser drauf zu. Das ist sicherlich so nicht gekommen. Also das ist nicht wirklich abgehoben. Die Leute wollen in der Regel doch lieber, sobald eine Firma eine gewisse Größenordnung erreicht, dass sie sich irgendwo einen eigenen System-Administrator leisten kann, dann stehen, glaube ich, die ersten Rechner dann doch wieder in der Firma. Also das mag man nicht, wenn irgendwie die Sachen so da draußen liegen.
Ja, ich meine, warum sie das anbieten, ist klar. Es ist halt einfach, man kann das halt dann im Web machen. Das gibt es halt derzeit nicht. Und wie gesagt, Google bietet alles an, was die Leute gerne haben wollen, damit sie eben einen Grund haben, Google zu benutzen. So, aber jetzt sollten wir vielleicht nochmal auf deine Frage eingehen. Aber, ähm, hattest du eine Frage, Andy?
Okay, achso, dann danke für deinen Anruf. Okay, tschüss. Tschüss. Komm, der hängt auch so ewig in der Leitung schon. Rigma! Hallo, Entschuldigung, nichts für ungut. Gehört dazu.
Alles klar, hallo aus Hamburg.
Ähm, ja, also ich wollte schon ganz am Anfang, als ihr beruhigend geredet habt, was da zu sagen. Und zwar ihr sagt ja schon die ganze Zeit, Google bietet das an, was die Leute haben wollen. Und ich bin nämlich genau wie du, Holgi, auf Google Mail irgendwann gekommen, vor zwei Jahren.
Und bevor ich wusste, was ich tat, hatte ich meine gesamte Kommunikation umorganisiert und die läuft jetzt über Google.
Sieht das bei mir auch so ähnlich, es gibt nur noch einen Mail-Account, der außenrum läuft bei mir.
Und es ist einfach sau praktisch, ich will das benutzen, das ist gut. Und die Sache ist, die ich hab dann mal auch nachgedacht, weil ich bin mir ja schon bewusst, dass das problematisch sein könnte, mal zumindest, und ob man das nicht mal, ob ich das nicht auf meinen eigenen Server mir einen ähnlichen Dienst lege. Und dann hab ich mal geguckt, so hab mir verschiedene Webmailer angeguckt und so AJAX-basierte Programme. Aber so das richtig gute, also Roundcube fand ich gar nicht so schlecht, aber ansonsten hat mich das alles nicht so wirklich überzeugt.
Und die Sache ist, gibt's da was?
Wisst ihr was, wo ich sagen kann, okay, das kann ich mir auf meinem eigenen Webseber installieren, hab ich Mail und die auch.
Google Mail, Google Mail-Klon für zu Hause.
Genau, also weil das versetzt dann eben doch eine Reihe von Leuten, es reicht ja dann, wenn sie jemanden kennen, dem sie vertrauen, Anführungsstrichen, der das kann. Das versetzt viele Leute in die Lage, dass sie zumindest mal so nicht so alles offenlegen müssen.
Brauchst du denn unbedingt einen Web-Mailer? Bist du halt viel unterwegs, ich sag mal, in Internet-Cafés oder in fremden Rechnern, dass du über einen Web-Mailer zugreifst und nicht über jetzt den Mail kleint auf deinem Rechner? Hast du kein Laptop?
Ich hab ein Laptop, aber ehrlich gesagt schleppe ich das Ding sehr ungern mit mir rum.
Ah, das ist zu groß.
Genau und ich bin schon relativ viel an fremden Rechnern, weil ich halt Rechnersupport mache.
Ja, also ich kann, also wir nutzen beispielsweise PHP-Mail einfach. Das ist ein sehr einfaches. Wir, das ist so die Gruppe, du gehörst zu ihnen.
Deine Firmenidentität.
Ja, genau, das ist jetzt meine dritte Identität. Genau da nutzen wir als Webmailer halt PHP Mail, was einfach nur ein kleiner Layer vor einem IMAP Server ist. Und eigentlich ist halt das, was man haben will, meiner Meinung nach, irgendwo ein IMAP Server. Da liegt die ganze Mail, da wird alles verwaltet. Und dann kann man sich beliebige Webmailer einfach mal ausprobieren. Und davor setzen und kann eben auch Mail-Clients benutzen aller Art. Das ist, denke ich, den Weg, den man da empfehlen würde zu gehen.
Im Prinzip habe ich das auch versucht. Also ich habe mir ein paar angeguckt. Es gibt ja auch Online-Demos von den ganzen PAP-Webmailern, also auch von Square-Mail und Roundcube ist eigentlich ganz nett. Aber es sind immer so Details, die fehlen. Also jetzt zum Beispiel auch dieses Texte und Tabellen, was es bei Google gibt und all so ein Kram.
Das ist wirklich sau praktisch.
Da legen wir halt auch eine ganze Menge Geld in das Development rein. Und ich denke derzeit im Web, also im Anwendung moderner Web-Anwendung ist auf jeden Fall Google ganz weit vorne. Es gibt da wenige, die da technisch mithalten können. Das sieht man an allen Produkten, Google Maps und so weiter. Die haben es halt verstanden mit dem Internet. Das muss man wirklich attestieren. Und daran geht auch Microsoft halt geradezu.
Ja, da sitzen auch eine Menge gute Leute. Also kennen eine ganze Reihe auch persönlich und doch, das ist schon ganz, ganz okay. Soweit technisch, was sie machen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, kann ich auch nur aus meiner Erfahrung auch sagen.
Aber ihr wisst nichts, was ähnlich, sagen wir mal, ähnlich komfortabel wäre.
Wahrscheinlich hätte das längst die Runde gemacht, wenn es das gäbe.
Naja, stimmt.
Ja, dann sollte ich unbedingt einen Weckruf an all die Open Source Programmierer mit viel zu viel Zeit auszusenden, dass sie sowas mal realisieren.
Ja, das wird wahrscheinlich einfach mit etwas Verzögerung eintreffen.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Wenn es zu spät ist.
Das denke ich schon.
Danke für deinen Anruf, Regma. Und ich begrüße Christoph. Hallo Christoph.
Ja, hi. Und zwar geht es bei mir indirekt um das Thema Amstetten.
Amstetten? Schulmassaker.
Genau, sozusagen. Ja, den Herrn Bastian Bosse, den kannte ich halt persönlich. So circa zwei bis drei Jahre. Der war Moderator auf meinem Forum. Und...
Warte mal, jetzt muss man doch fragen, weil ich das nicht so verfolgt habe. Bastian Bosse ist wer? Das ist derjenige, der da rumgelaufen ist?
Okay, hol mal ein Stück aus Christoph. Also M. Stetten, das war das letzte größere Schulmassaker. Der ist in die Schule gekommen und hat was genau gemacht?
Also ja, im Grunde genommen ist er da herumgelaufen und hat Leute angeschossen. Und dann hat er sich selbst erschossen.
Okay, das war die Person, die du gerade gerade hast.
Ja, und zwar... Genau, er war mein Moderator und... Unser Thema ist halt das Columbine High School Massaker. Und da besprechen wir halt einige Themen, die recht aktuell sind momentan. Und ja, ich kannte ihn halt ein bisschen länger, auch durch diverse Chats und dachte eigentlich, dass es ihm besser ging. Ich kannte auch seinen Live Journal, ich kannte verschiedene Seiten von ihm, hab die aber nicht immer permanent verfolgt. Und ich hab mir da auch nichts Großartiges gedacht, weil ich auch nicht so viel Zeit in der letzten Zeit hatte für ihn. Naja, auf jeden Fall war es dann halt dieser Montag, der 20. November. Naja, ich war bei der Arbeit, hab dann meine E-Mails gecheckt, hab Fernsehen geguckt und eine E-Mail von ihm gekriegt. Die letzte sozusagen mit einigen Links. Und darin stand halt, waren seine Videos, waren seine Bilder, alle Auszeichnungen, seine ganzen Profile waren da drin. Und sozusagen das ganze Web 2.0 wurde da ausgenutzt. Als Promotion für ihn. Ja, und dann circa ein, zwei Tage später, da ich auch ein Profil bei Live Journal habe, das direkt auf sein Profil verlinkt ist, weil er nicht so viele Freunde hatte, stand dann halt sozusagen die Polizei bei mir vor der Tür. Bei dir vor der Tür? Genau. Also, naja, ich bin zum Polizeirevier gefahren und die stand sozusagen schon bei mir vor der Tür. Ich musste dann halt verschiedene Fragen klären und alles. Das war halt sehr abenteuerlich für mich.
Was siehst du da jetzt für Ansichten, Konsequenzen oder Einsichten draus?
Ja, im Grunde, mir war das zweimal bewusst, dass man so viele Sachen, wie man mich herausfinden kann und dass die Polizei auch die Möglichkeit hat, an verschiedene Sachen reinzukommen. Aber wenn man dann halt in so einem Büro sitzt, vor irgendwelchen wild träumten Leuten und die wirklich alle Fotos von einem haben und die wirklich die tiefsten Geheimnisse, die man einem Live-Journal da irgendwie anvertraut vor sich liegen kann, dann wird es recht unangenehm.
Und es waren keine öffentlichen Dinge, sondern eigentlich Sachen, die du nur einer geschützten oder einer kontrollierten Gruppe eigentlich veröffentlicht hast. Und die lagen alle dann komplett schon bei der Polizei auf dem Tisch ausgedruckt, oder?
Das war ein geschlossenes Forum, ja? Also so ein eigener Server, wo nur ein paar Leute drauf waren?
Das war jetzt auf Live-Journal. Also das waren die Inhalte von Live-Journal. Mein Forum hab ich am Dingentag dann direkt offline gezogen. Da das alles datenbankbasierend ist, hab ich einfach nur die Datenbank gelöscht und da kommen wir dann auch nicht mehr hinterher. Und die Polizei, die hat eigentlich auch nicht so viel Arbeit gemacht. Da war nämlich die Presse sozusagen derjenige, der vermittelt hat und das dann an die Polizei weitergeleitet hat.
Warum hast du deine Datenbank gelöscht?
Weil ich Angst hatte, dass da irgendwie die ganzen Medien und sich die ganze Presse da drauf stürzen und mich sozusagen in die Öffentlichkeit ziehen.
Als sozusagen der beste Freund oder der wer auch immer.
Oder als der Co-Killer.
Ja genau, das ist ziemlich einfach, da diese Seite recht provokant aufgemacht ist. Wenn man ein bisschen weiter liest, dann merkt man dann halt auch, dass diese Provokation speziell gewählt wurde, um die Leute halt aufmerksam zu machen, dass viele Leute, die halt auch selber provozieren, im Grunde genommen auch Probleme haben und diese dann halt ein bisschen anders als andere Leute regeln. Die sind halt ruhiger, provozieren halt mit ihrem Aussehen und irgendwann mal kann es halt passieren, dass das alles ausbricht.
Immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, drei Stunden lang Blumen mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Das Ganze heißt Chaos Radio. Heute ist Chaos Radio 121. 21 digitale Identitäten ist unser Thema im Studio Pavel, Tim und Holgi. Digital Identitäten im Chaos Radio 121 und White Ninja hat angerufen.
Hallo, White Ninja.
Ist das dein richtiger Name?
Nein, natürlich nicht. Er hat das ganz clever geregelt. Sein Nachname ist eigentlich White.
Nein, nein, mein Name ist White Ninja, weil ich unter anderem mit dem Begriff des White Noise arbeite. Das heißt also das Rauschen in der Wissens- und Informationsgesellschaft. Und ich habe einen Freund, der hat Catcam Video und Mac5 oder wie das alles heißt. Und da braucht man sich dann nur hinstellen und sagen, mach doch mal an. Und dann schaltet er mir Google, YouTube, eine Sendung an und da merke ich, da ist eine Frau oder ein Mann mit Berücke und erzählt Stimmen verzerrt etwas. Dann gab es dann noch eine Kondomreklame, wo ein perfektioniertes Kondom gezeigt wurde, aber der der Vorführer vom Kopf her nicht sichtbar war. Dann kenne ich mich in Pornofilmen aus und hab mir gedacht, man wir suchen einen schönen Hintergrund bei James in der Wohnung. Und ich erzähle meine Sprüche als white Ninja, Master und Pornostar. Und nun bin ich da und sammle in der Metaebene die Meinungen. Der eine sagt zum Beispiel, ich sehe so viel im Netz, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich dich gesehen habe. Der andere sagt, er hat keinen DSL Anschluss, weil es so lange dauert. Der dritte sagt, das lief nicht. Der vierte telefoniert dabei, während er sich das ansieht. Und keiner hat alle 12 Filme gesehen. Und ich versuchte halt eben Kunst oder Konzeptkunst oder dieses Ding auszunutzen und als älterer Herr einen frischen Eindruck zu machen. Aber was ich da genau mache, das weiß ich nicht. Aber meine Identität white Ninja ist dort submedial. Oder das versuche ich jetzt auch über dieses Telefonat zu erweitern. White Ninja steht für kein Heldentum, kein Führer-Tum.
Ich hab jetzt bei YouTube mal geguckt, da gibt's einen fetten white Ninja.
Nein, nein, Mono Man on Air ist das Ganze. Also James, der ist Mono Man on Air. Und wenn wir Musik machen, bin ich Ego Man on Air.
Das heißt, du hast angerufen, um Werbung zu machen?
Nein, ich wollte eben auf diese White Noise-Geschichte hinweisen. Von wegen, was passiert da überhaupt? Während man face to face dort meinen Lava-Kram oder meinen Pornostar oder meine Reklame, lach ich ruhig, sieht. Und auf der anderen Seite eben, wie weit kann dann, wenn ich dort eine Sonnenbrille trage oder diese Identität überhaupt? Weil es ist ja kontextuell bedingt. Ich bin ja dort in einem 16 zu 9 Verhältnis. Und weiß eben aufgrund der zwei Filme, die ich vorher gesehen habe, da wird sich der eine eine Perücke aufsetzen und verzerrt seine Stimme. Und der zweite lässt noch nicht mal seinen Kopf abbilden. Und ich setze mir eine Sonnenbrille halt eben auf. Man wird mich ja bei der Pixelzahl, das ist übrigens mein Lieblingsausdruck in einem dieser Filme, jedes Pixel kostet Strom. Ich weise auf diese CO2-Strom. Also ich bin so ein Ökospezialist. Also ich versuche natürlich, Reklame zu machen, gebe ich ruhig zu. Aber im Sinne von White Noise, Heroism, Leadership.
Okay, kannst du das vielleicht mal mit einer URL konkretisieren? Weil ich hab hier gerade so... Na, was man so in seinen Webbrowser eingibt, um gleich ein Ergebnis zu bekommen.
Also Google, YouTube, Broadcast yourself und dann Mono Man on Air 12 Buchstaben ein Wort. Mono Man on Erde, das war ein Kommentar.
Schauen wir mal. Schärfen im Radio, super Sache.
Das ist doch schon mal was.
Und ich hab das halt eben im November bei James gemacht. Und war gerade, ja, ich dachte wir brauchen guten Hintergrund. Und dieses White Ninja ist auch so ein Minimal Approach, diese Konzeptkunst, das heißt.
Das ist auch super, wenn du dir das anguckst, White Ninja Part 7, da wird dann rechts unten so empfohlen, was man vielleicht noch gucken könnte. Stahlgewitter, Ruhm und Ehre der Waffen SS.
Oh, war ja nicht.
Weiße Wölke, Wölfe, Ruhm und Ehre. Bei mir steht das, Ruhm und Ehre der deutschen Wehrmacht.
Das ist ja das Peinliche, dass bei White Ninja, obwohl ich hier mit dem Begriff White Ninja arbeite, also es ist Ruhm und Ehre und Schuld und Sühne, da vergleiche ich die beiden Religionen miteinander, dass eben bedauerlicherweise, wenn ich das von James mitgeteilt bekommen habe, 300 Leute da angeklickt haben. Ich vermute, das sind, sagen wir mal, 50 Controller, die denken, was ist das für einer? Aber der Rest sind Nazis und das finde ich auch wieder äußerst peinlich. Hier in meinem Tagebuch habe ich während dieser Sendung aufgeschrieben, das kann doch nicht sein, dass Google Antworten, Auswerten von Worten, dass es dann doch um diese Text geht. Mein nächstes Wort wäre dann eben sexualisierte Senioren oder Silver Sexer, wie es im Globalen heißt. Und dann wäre wieder mein deutsches White Ninja und SS. Und das kann es nicht sein.
Ja, ich bin total weg. Also, ja, du hast recht.
Also Google, auswerten von Worten, das kam von euch sogar.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Aspekt nochmal, wo, wenn Video gezeigt wird, kommt nochmal eine zusätzliche Dimension auf jeden Fall dazu von Identität. Das ist definitiv ein Punkt.
Bist du denn ansonsten im Internet unter deiner Real, also bist du überhaupt mit deiner realen Identität im Internet unterwegs?
Nee, das ist ja der Haken. Ich bin ja eben postmodener Kybernetiker und sag den Leuten immer, mich kannst du um 10 Uhr anrufen. Und dann möchte ich bitte nur wissen, wann ich wo sein soll. Okay, wir sprechen jetzt virtuell am Telefon, aber Minimal Approach ist eben die Konzeptkunst und ich weiche ab vom Ideal in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt hier mit euch rede, aber ich versuche die Leute darauf hinzuweisen, ihr guckt alle auf 16 zu 9 Format und es sind alles Pixels, die Strom kosten und wo ist der Content, was läuft da überhaupt? Oder Wikipedia, wenn man das auf den Printmedien herausholt.
Ja, das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall nochmal ein anderer großer Punkt, aber wir sind ja mehr bei den Identitäten.
Aber trotzdem mit den Stromkosten und Pixeln war ja noch das Ding. Weil du Second Life erwähntest, das hattest du mitgekriegt, dass ein Second Life Avatar mehr Strom verbraucht als ein echter Brasilianer?
Heißt das, dass der Brasilianer jetzt überflüssiger ist als ein Avatar?
Das will man nicht den Brasilianer nennen, sondern als ein realer Mensch in der dritten Welt.
Nein, das ist, wenn man es wirklich vergleicht, es gibt Schätzungen, dass ein Second Life Avatar etwa 2200 Kilowattstunden pro Jahr verschlingt.
Dass mehr Strom als nicht verbraucht wird.
Also in den Industrieländern sind es irgendwie pro Kopf durchschnittlich etwas über 7000 Kilowattstunden. 7000 Kilowattstunden sind es in den Industrieländern und Brasilien deswegen, weil Brasilien irgendwo bei 1700 Kilowattstunden pro Jahr halt...
Jetzt muss ich mal nach der Quelle fragen. Hast du die parat?
Chat, Antworten.
Das ist einmal diese Energiefrage und zur anderen Seite eben dieses White Noise. Rauschen in der Wissens- und Informationsgesellschaft. Wer produziert das Wissen? Das kann doch nicht sein, dass Google und Wikipedia das Wissen produzieren. Das geht doch nicht. Die gute Gutenberg Galaxies. Oder ich hör hier gerade ein paar Radiosender sind ja noch gut. EURA zurzeit heute Abend auch. Blabla. Das ist hier Stoundal. Rot und schwarz. Das kann ich nur empfehlen. 92, 4. Jeden Tag um halb drei und um fünf Minuten nach 23. Da greifen die Leute immer auf Treppen und Leitern in eine Bibliothek und holen da irgendwelche Revolutionäre raus. Aber wie gesagt, ja, Cyberspace. Und jetzt hier diese bunten Bilder und da quatscht einer, ja ich bin Pornostar. Das ist doch Quatsch.
Wir nicken die Wörter. Bei einer Sache muss ich dir echt zustimmen. Dass Google und Wikipedia die einzigen Antworten liefern, das muss man auf jeden Fall verhindern. Man muss sich klar machen, dass das auf jeden Fall nicht alles ist. Das ist ganz klar.
Es ist echt zum Kotzen, dass die anderen Suchmaschinen so scheiße sind.
Wir sind ja noch weiter. Wir sind ja darüber hinaus noch an einem Punkt angelangt, wo Spiegel Online Agenda Setting macht. Also das ist ja der Wahnsinn. Also Google und Wikipedia liefern die Antworten und Agenda Setting. Also tagesordnungsbestimmt ist Spiegel Online.
Also Spiegel Online ist sozusagen die Wikipedia-Seite des Tages.
Was glaubst du, was in Redaktionen losgeht, solange es nicht auf Spiegel Online steht, ist es kein Thema, was in anderen Medien stattfindet.
Aber wird das noch so lange so bleiben?
Äh, ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass sich das so schnell noch ändern wird, nee.
Aber da sind wir wieder bei den Tags. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass die Welt nach... Deshalb versuch ich gerade jetzt eben mir die ganze Zeit den Kopf zu knacken, dieses Stoffenbuffer oder deine Dingsenbumsen.
Stackeblochen.
Ja, Stammelknochen.
Ja genau, so ein Wort.
Ich mein nein, Stackeblochen.
Wenn das bei Google durchkäme, das wäre doch mal ein Gag.
Wie durchkäme?
Ja, wenn das eben als Auswerten von Worten an Nummer 1 steht, weil es eben nicht Silversexer oder sexualisierte Senioren oder Ruhm und Ehre oder so ein Zirkus hat.
Ja, bei Google steht ja das am Anfang, was du suchst. Und wenn du nach Stackeblochen suchst, steht auch Stackeblochen am Pixel.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch eine Hitliste, die algorithmisch durch die irgendwie manipuliert, weiß ich nicht. Also wird schon irgendwo eine Rechnerei dahinter sein. Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert. Nach diesen Überschriften kann das Ganze doch nicht funktionieren.
Ok, Monoman. White Ninja.
Monoman war wieder die Version. Wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Ja, ich glaube, es war nicht zu lang.
Aber es war aufschlussreich.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu...
Ich lade mal eine Mate nach.
Ich lade meine Mate nach. Ich habe gerade einen Hustenreiz.
Pavel, du musst...
Soll ich mit husten?
Ach so, nein.
Die Pause, Pavel, schneller, schneller.
Pavel, Pavel, Pavelpause.
Andreas?
Hast du schon was zum Camp gesagt eigentlich? Bestimmt die Hörer, die in dem ersten Teil der Sendung zugehört haben, sind bestimmt nicht mehr da.
Die haben es keine fünf Minuten ausgehalten.
Das sind jetzt lauter neue Hörer.
Ja, das war ja mal ein Impact. Also ich meine, das ist...
Wie glauben die Leute sonst, was wir hier tun eigentlich?
So, nachdem Tim sich jetzt nass machen gegangen. Das beste ist ja das Atot, ne? Der ist die ganze Zeit schon on Air, aber der merkt das nicht. Der kann die ganze Zeit reinquatschen.
Ja, ich hatte das Mikro noch zu, aber guten Morgen.
Hallo. Wie du hattest das Mikro zu? Dann hättest du mal was gesagt, hättest die ganze Zeit dumm Zeug labern können, während wir hier fast erstickt wären.
Ihr hattet ja Spaß, das ist prima, aber seid froh, dass ihr nur unter Pseudonym in die Sendung gegangen seid. Ihr habt mir gerade eine prima Überleitung gegeben. Ich wollte noch um die Frage nach der Zuordnbarkeit und Zusammenführung von Identitäten aufwerfen.
Dann mal los.
Immerhin war es ja sowohl dir als auch den Anrufern recht wichtig, dass die Pseudonymen nicht genannt werden. Keine Ahnung, im sogenannten realen Leben, also das Ding außerhalb des Internets, gehören ja Pseudonymität und Anonymität immer noch zu normalen Bestandteilen des Lebens. Niemals käme mein Bäcker auf die Idee, mir einen Verso abzuverlangen, weil ich sagte, ich hätte gern vier Schritten. Oder auch bei dem Künstler gerade, ich hab seinen Namen schon wieder vergessen, White Ninja oder so. Das ist ja ganz offensichtlich Usus, dass es sich einen Schriftsteller, einen Sänger, einen Schauspieler, einen Künstlernamen gibt. Damit er halt auch beim Einchecken ins Hotel noch klarkommt.
Ich weiß es gar nicht. Geben sie sich deshalb Künstlernamen? Danke.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ruf nochmal an, White Ninja, ruf nochmal an. Warum gibst du dir einen Künstlernamen?
Warum machen das nicht alle Künstler?
Ja, aber warum? Weil es alle Künstler machen?
Ja, wir machen das, weil es alle machen.
Das muss man machen, weil man es machen muss.
Das geht ja auch gar nicht anders, weil es ja gar nicht anders geht.
Also kannst du nicht mal die schöne Geschichte erzählen mit. Wie hieß er noch gleich? Herr Thoman?
Ja, Paul Thoman, von wegen Künstlername. Es gab auf der Biennale in Sao Paulo eine Veranstaltung, wo die Gruppe Monochrom dahin gefahren ist als Vertreter der Republik Österreich. Und Johannes Grenzfurtner hat eine Installation da gemacht.
Was ist die Gruppe Monochrom?
Eine Kunstneigungsgruppe aus Wien, also Künstler. Und er ging über diese Veranstaltung und war dort akkreditiert als das technische Personal des Künstlers, Georg-Paul Thoeman, obwohl er natürlich selbst der Künstler war. Und seine Kunst war einen fiktiven Künstler zu schaffen, nämlich Georg-Paul Thoeman. Und die Republik Österreich war vertreten durch Georg-Paul Thoeman. Aber er war halt immer in seinem Hotel und war noch betrunken. Und namhafte Künstler aus anderen Ländern kamen und fragten ihn so, wo ist denn eigentlich der Thoeman? Den habe ich ja schon so lange nicht gesehen. Man sitz im Hotel und seufzt und die Künstler haben darauf geantwortet, ach ja, den sah ich ja schon ewig nicht, bestell ihm doch mal schöne Grüße. Er hat gesagt, klar, mach ich. Und das ist ja auch so eine Spannung in der digitalen Zeit, dass Wahrheit und Fiktion ununterscheidbar geworden sind. Denn die, die ihn nicht kannten, konnten in Google Georg-Paul Thoeman eingeben. Und da fanden sie eine kopierte Umrechnungstabelle Euro in Schilling, die als Selbstportrait von Georg-Paul Thoeman das bekannte Kunstwerk war, das er ja ausgestellt hat. Und das aktuell von ihm ausgestellte Kunstwerk war halt so ein bärtiger Österreicher mit einer Flasche Bier durch einen Wachsfilter in Photoshop geschickt. Selbstportrait nach Wachsfilter. Auch schon.
Georg-Paul Thoeman ist verstorben, habe ich jetzt gar nicht.
Das war ja zwei Jahre später, dann sind sie ihn auch noch begraben.
Über OTS haben sie es rausgegeben, das ist super.
Und alle haben das geglaubt. Und dann wollte Johannes sich den Ausstellungskatalog abholen, um eben zu Hause auch diesen tollen Ausstellungskatalog zu haben, der ihn daran erinnert, was er da für einen Stand gebracht hat. Und die meinten, das dürfe nur der Künstler selbst und nicht das niedere technische Personal. Das niedere technische Personal hätte hier nichts verloren. Daraufhin hat er angefangen, den Leuten zu erzählen, dass das alles nur ein Fake war. Und sie haben es ihm nicht geglaubt. Meinten, du willst ja nur einen Katalog abgreifen. Und das geht ja ganz offensichtlich sehr weit. Also es ist immerhin eine weltweite Grundausstellung. Und das ist auch die Frage, wie weit geht denn dann so diese Zuschreibung, was vorhin auch der Anrufer gesagt hatte, wie weit geht dieses Eigenleben von Pseudonymen, wenn dir plötzlich Dinge zugeschrieben werden? Weil Steif und Fest, der Künstler aus Schweden behauptet, den kenne ich mit. Den habe ich schon letztes Mal hier mir an der Nibeländer gesoffen. Und letztlich ist halt die Frage nach der Zusammenführung dieser Daten und wie weit es noch Beweiswert in digitalen Zeiten hat, weil man sich ja seinen Pseudonym unterfüttern kann, weil man sich einen plausiblen Namen nimmt. Sei es, weil man sich das Telefonbuch nehmen kann und einen statistisch im Mittel liegenden Namen findet. Die Serie Schimanski heißt ja auch, soweit es den Kerle in Düsseldorf im Telefonbuch gab. Wie auch immer Tim auf seinen Namen kam, wie auch immer ich auf meinen Namen kam. Aber eben diese Zuartenbarkeit, dass was du mit 15 unter möglicherweise einem Pseudonym, möglicherweise nicht in irgendeiner Webseite geschrieben hast, wird dir einfach in zehn Jahren nachkommen. Besser unter dem Pseudonym, nichtsdestotrotz ist ja die Frage, wenn wir dann Bilder haben oder Rufnummern und diese Zuordnung stattfinden kann plötzlich, dann holt dich das ja möglicherweise irgendwann ein und dein Personalchef sagt, dich nehme ich aber nicht von dir, ist ein Bild, wo du betrunken auf einer Webseite stehst. Auf irgendeiner Party.
Demnächst ist wahrscheinlich sowieso jeder betrunken, auf irgendeinem Foto im Internet zu finden. Aber wie hältst du es denn selber mit der Anno oder Pseudonymität oder Identität? Und was wäre deine Empfehlung für die Leute?
Eine strikte Trennung ist schon mal hilfreich, denke ich. Einfach zu sagen, eine Berufsnummer und eine Postanschrift und eine Mailadresse verwende ich im Kontext des Chaos Computer Clubs, im Kontext meiner Hochschule, im Kontext meiner beruflichen Tätigkeit etc. Sodass man da auch filtern kann und sagen kann, heute will ich aber mal mich auf irgendwas konzentrieren und das andere spezifisch ausblenden. Wie weit dann das gelingt, ist so eine Frage. Früher war es einfach möglich, bei der zweiten Türe, die hat eine andere Anschrift, diese Anschrift zu verwenden und der Postbote wusste, dass es ein und derselbe Briefkasten. Ich gehe halt Türe 1 oder Türe 2 rein und dann stehe ich vor der Briefkastenwand. Hilft mir aber nichts, wenn jeder beliebige 14-jährige, das in mapsgoogle.de eintippen kann und sieht, dass es ein Egghouse ist. Das ist ja auch eine graduelle Veränderung. Und letztlich denke ich, gibt es ja technische Mittel, beispielsweise auch Anonymisierungsdienste, die es erlauben, dass man diese Rekonstruktion unterbrechen kann. Da ist aber halt auch die Frage, wie weit wird mir das noch im Rechtsrahmen erlaubt werden, wenn der Staat sagt, eine wirksame Anonymisierung muss sich verbieten. Und dann kann ich mir zwar noch ein Pseudonym wählen. Und ich darf es auch nutzen, um auf der AIDS-Info-Seite rumzulaufen, um auf der missbrauchte Kindergruppe rumzuklicken, um auf was auch immer.
Also mit Anonymisierung meinst du jetzt die Anonymisierung der Identität oder die Anonymisierung des Surfens im Internet?
Die Anonymisierung der Zuordnung zwischen mir als Person und dem von mir gewählten Pseudonym. Und diese Zuordnung darf nicht gespeichert werden, bin ich der Ansicht. Und der Staat sagt, wenn Leute Pseudonyme benutzen wollen, dann müssen wir diese Zuordnung jederzeit herstellen können. Und das führt das ganze ad absurdum. Denn wenn es eine Datenbank gibt, in der diese Zuordnungen sind, dann wird sie irgendjemand nutzen. Denn Datenbestände, hast du vorhin gesagt, becken Begehrlichkeiten. Und da ist halt auch die Frage, wie weit es dann geht. Und meinem Bäcker ist es egal, ob ich da nun als Peter oder Frank oder Stefan auftrete. Dem kümmert das einfach mal nicht, so lange ich meine 60 Cent bezahle. Aber wenn das weitergeht, beispielsweise dieses berühmte Telekom Urteil, da gab es, da schweife ich jetzt ein bisschen ab, da gab es eine Geheimnummer. Und diese Geheimnummer führte zu so einem Dienst für Missbrauch der Frauen. In so einem Frauenhaus. Und die Telekom hat diese Nummer ins Telefonbuch eingetragen, worauf die erst mal umgezogen sind. Und dann gab es halt die Klage, ob die Telekom diesen Umzug bezahlen muss, was sie dann tun musste, weil eben genau diese Zuordnung zwischen Identitäten, nämlich zwischen diesem Gebäude und dieser Rufnummer gemacht werden konnte. Und das gilt halt für beliebige andere Beispiele auch, zum Beispiel die Weblogs, die jetzt gerade aus dem Iran kommen, die Weblogs, die in Russland noch unzensiert stattfinden, die uns sagen, was da gerade passiert, wo eben versucht wird, eine Identität zwischen dem Bloggenden oder sei es China, zwischen dem Bloggenden und der Person herzustellen, um ihn mal publikumswirksam aus der Vorlesung in der Hochschule zu zerren und auf offener Straße zu verprügeln, damit ein Exempel statuiert wird und allen anderen klar ist, ihr bloggt jetzt mal nicht, was ihr Phase ist, denn die Meinung dominiert die staatliche Nachrichtenagentur.
Wie ist denn so deine persönliche Einschätzung? Gibt es jetzt noch eine Zukunft für die Anonymität? Zum Beispiel in Deutschland, in Europa?
Ich denke, das hängt immer ab für wen und wem gegenüber.
Also für den Webbenutzer, sagen wir mal so. Der sich irgendwo registriert und ein unbeobachtetes digitales Leben führen möchte.
Nicht mehr, wenn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kommen wird gegenüber dem Staat. Ob der diese Datenbestände privaten zur Verfügung stellen wird, ist noch so eine Frage. Es gibt allerdings noch Instrumente wie Tor oder auch spezifisch für einzelne Dienste, zum Beispiel mailinator.com. Das ist ein Dienst, der beliebige generierte Mail-Adressen weiterleitet. anonbox.net, was der Club auch betreibt. mailinator.com Genau und anonbox.net, das sind mehr oder weniger anonyme oder pseudonyme Dienste, die Mail-Adressen bereitstellen, die dann abgerufen werden können. Das heißt, du kannst dir eine Identität bei deinem Weblog-Provider eröffnen. Und dessen Kennzeichen, dessen Personen-Kennzeichen, das dir zugeordnet ist, ist eine Mail-Adresse, zu der es keine Zuordnung zu dir gibt. Das war ja früher auch bei Anon... Penetfee, Penetic Eur AB, was Jules Felsingius betrieben hat, 1993 die Geschichte mit der Church of Scientology, wo ja auch klar war, er unterbricht die Zuordnung zwischen einer Person, die die Geheimnisse der Church of Scientology veröffentlicht, nach Sicht der Scientology-Organisation, wurde aber dazu gezwungen, durch die finnische Polizei diese Zuordnung auszuhändigen und an die Church of Scientology zu übergeben. Denn bei ihm existiert ja diese Zuordnung. Und das Wichtige wird einfach sein, diese Zuordnung nicht zu haben, nicht bestehen zu lassen, denn dann kann dich niemand zwingen, sie zu übergeben. Aber die Frage ist immer, wem gegenüber. Einem Webseitenbetreiber wirst du das vermutlich auf absehbare Zeit sehr gut, wenn du das technische Know-how hast, verhindern können, dass diese Information liegt. Wie Pavel schon sagt, man hat dann halt einen Mail-Account hier, einen Mail-Account da, einen Mail-Account da. Man kann seine Identitäten entsprechend aufbauen gegenüber verschiedenen Gruppen. Funktioniert, wenn man sich die Mühe macht, das hat man ja auch mehrfach gehört heute, gegenüber einem starken Angreifer wie einem Staat, der einfach jegliche Zuordnungen speichern wird. Jegliche Kommunikationsnutzung wird es nicht möglich sein.
Okay, nur noch mal vielleicht kurz reingetaucht hier anonbox.net. Ist ja auch ein Dienst von CCC.
Wollen wir hier gerade mal Nachrichten machen, weil wir sind ja auch dann...
Ah, oh stimmt, wir haben es 34.
Okay, bleibt da.
Genau.
Das neue Fritz Radiospiel, bei dem alle gewinnen oder keiner.
10 Runden an 10 Tagen.
Und nur, wenn jeder Einzelne Mitspieler gewinnt, gewinnen alle.
Jeder einen Einkaufsgutschein im Wert von 200 Euro von Nike Town in der Townsendstraße Berlin.
Aber wenn nur einer verliert, gewinnt keiner. Und das Spiel ist im Eimer. Und dann geht's wieder von vorne los.
So lange, bis alle gewinnen.
Alle oder keiner.
Das neue Fritz Radiospiel, bei dem alle gewinnen oder keiner.
Montag bis Freitag bei den Radio-Fritzen am Morgen. Immer um 7 Uhr 20. Natürlich auf 5 und das hört man 5 nachher bei 1.
Mache ich mit.
In Italien hat die Mitte-Links-Regierung von Ministerpräsident Prodi die Vertrauensabstimmung im Senat gewonnen. Die Senatoren votiert mit 162 gegen 157 Stimmen für den Regierungschef. Da er in der Abgeordnetenkammer über eine klare Mehrheit verfügt, kann er mit seiner Mitte-Links-Koalition weiter regieren. Staatspräsident Napolitano hatte Prodi nach seinem Rücktrittsgesuch aufgefordert, nochmals einen Neuanfang zu versuchen. Aus Protest gegen den geplanten Stellenabbau bei Airbus haben Beschäftigte in Deutschland und Frankreich gestern ihre Arbeit niedergelegt. In den deutschen Werken Pharell, Nordenham und Laubheim soll die Arbeit nach Angaben der EG Metall vor Freitag nicht wieder aufgenommen werden. Airbus hatte angekündigt, in den nächsten vier Jahren 10.000 Stellen zu streichen, 3.700 davon in Deutschland. Der Bayer-Schering-Konzern will an seinem Hauptsitz in Berlin knapp 1.000 Stellen abbauen, das bestätigte der Vorstand von Bayer in Berlin. Bis Mitte 2008 soll aber auf betriebsbedingte Kündigungen verzichtet werden. Für 350 Mitarbeiter seien bereits individuelle Lösungen wie Ruhestandsregelungen, Altersteilzeit oder Abfindungen gefunden worden. In Niedersachsen sind im Garten eines Privatmannes rund 110 Gramm angereichertes Uran sichergestellt worden. Es sei Material, das in deutschen Atomkraftwerken verwendet wird, teilte das niedersächsische Umweltministerium mit. Eine akute Gesundheitsgefahr sei davon nicht ausgegangen. Der Gartensitzer löste die Suchert-Aktion selbst mit einem Brief an das Kanzleramt aus. Angaben zur Herkunft des Urans machte er nicht. Hertha BSC ist im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals ausgeschieden, die Berliner verloren beim VfB Stuttgart mit 2 zu 0. Viele Wolken und etwas Regen heute Nacht. Bis morgen früh wird der Regen dann immer weniger. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 4 Grad. Tagsüber dann weiterhin viele Wolken und auch wieder Regen, aber auch etwas Sonne bei maximal 10 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz, keine Störungen zurzeit, gute Fahrt.
Ritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 1, dann Fritz in der Prignitz.
Chaosradio 121, digitale Identitäten und Arthod ist immer noch am Telefon. Wo war mich stehen geblieben?
Arthod wollte noch mal kurz erläutern wie Anonbox jetzt mal als konkretes Beispiel, wie man seine digitale Identität zumindest etwas verstecken kann, konkret funktioniert.
Genau, da gabs. Was ich vorhin schon erzählt hatte, ein Remailer in Finnland, der hatte den Nachteil, der hat eine Mailadresse generiert, der Form 12345 und hat dir diese Post weitergeschickt. Das heißt aber, der wusste deine E-Mail-Adresse, denn er musste dir das ja irgendwie zukommen lassen. Wir haben jetzt unter Anonbox-Net als Club versucht, das Ganze zu umgehen. Wir verschenken auch Einmaladressen. Die haben allerdings zwei Unterschiede. Zum einen leiten wir keinen Post weiter, sondern die kann man über eine Webseite abfragen. Das hat den großen Vorteil, man kann mit einem Anonymeiser dahin gehen. Das heißt, wir wissen nicht, wer da ankommt. Das interessiert uns zwar auch nicht, aber man kann von einer beliebigen Adresse kommen. Das heißt, die Identität kennen wir nicht. Und zum anderen schmeißen wir die Adresse nach 48 Stunden weg. Das heißt, selbst wenn irgendjemand auf die Idee käme, das prüfen zu wollen, ist es 48 Stunden später einfach weg. Die Mailbox existiert nicht mehr, die Mail ist da nicht mehr.
Aber solange werden die Mail da gespeichert sozusagen?
Genau. Und der Sinn dahinter ist, es existieren da virtuelle Postfläche. Und wenn man sich ein Dokument zumailen lassen will, hat man bis um Mitternacht des darauffolgenden Tages Zeit, sich eine Mail zukommen zu lassen, indem man jemand diese Mailadresse aushändigt. Und über eine Webseite kann man diese Mailadresse abfragen und dann sieht man die Mail dahinter.
Und ist das Angebot als solches jetzt rechtlich eigentlich auch in Gefahr?
Nach Ansicht unserer Juristen nicht. Da ist allerdings die Frage, wie weit das mit der Umsetzung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung noch so sein wird. Das Problem ist hier, dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung verlangt, dass Anonymisierungsdienste zuordnen, wer sie genutzt hat zu tatsächlichen Personen. Wie sich das technisch umsetzen lässt, ist ohnehin noch mal so eine Frage. Aber das interessiert den Gesetzgeber ja nicht. Zum anderen gibt es in Deutschland interessanterweise immer noch zwei Gesetze, nämlich eins für die Fraktion Datenschutz sozusagen, beispielsweise akutes Zähledienst-Datenschutzgesetz und dann eins für die Strafverfolger. Der Gesetzgeber drückt sich seit Jahren darum, diesen Interessensausgleich, der in der Demokratie Stand der Dinge ist, durchzuführen und hat einfach beiden Seiten jeweils ihr Gesetz geschenkt. Im Zweifel muss dann irgendein armer Dorfrichter herausfinden, wie man da die Karten in der Hand hält.
Wenn die Vorratsdatenspeicherung durchkommt, habe ich überhaupt keine Chance mehr, meine Kommunikation in irgendeiner Form, also nicht mehr zuordnenbar zu machen, dass ich mit irgendjemandem kommuniziere und was ich da kommuniziere? Kann ich da nur noch ein Ad-hoc-Netzwerk mit mehreren Laptops aufbauen, das dann quasi als Intranet oder wie auch immer ich es nennen mag, sicher ist?
Mutmaßlich ist die Frage, wie es umgesetzt werden wird, aber so wie das im Augenblick aussieht, wird es einfach keine Telekommunikationsanschlüsse mehr geben, bei denen nicht die Kennung des Anschlusses mit einer Person verbunden wird, und zwar in der Regel zusammen mit einer vom Staat ausgegebenen Form des Identitätsnachweises. Das ist ja heute schon so, wenn man sich eine Telefonkarte kauft, einen Mobilfunkvertrag abschließt, muss man seine Reisepass- oder Personalausweisnummer angeben. Das heißt, es gibt eine tatsächlich zu einer in einer staatlichen Datenbank verfügbaren Person zuordnbaren Kennungen zu diesem, aber im Internetcafé noch nicht. Gut, aber das im Internetcafé noch nicht.
Aber das also die Vorratsdaten Speicherung wird natürlich nur vor allem, ich sag mal, ehrliche normale Nutzer betreffen. Also wirklich kriminelle Aktivitäten werden dadurch wahrscheinlich kaum erschwert, weil da gibt es mit ein bisschen kriminelle Energie ransetzt, kann man sich ja nun auch alle Arten von falschen Identitäten in der realen Welt besorgen, als Grundlage wiederum nimmt. Oder die Welt ist halt groß. Ich meine im Moment schaffen es ja auch alle möglichen kriminellen Gelder aus Fishing-Aktionen irgendwie verschwinden zu lassen. Insofern wird es wahrscheinlich eher dazu führen, dass halt viele normale Leute wahrscheinlich davon in irgendeiner Art und Weise getroffen werden. Und betroffen werden beispielsweise bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen.
Jetzt kommen wir aber im Prinzip an den Ausgangspunkt der Sendung zurück. Nämlich so die Frage, was kann man eigentlich an Anonymität und Zordonymität und Identität überhaupt ausleben?
Eins, zwei und vielen Dank Arthur, wollte ich sagen. Und weil du gerade den Bogen machen willst, nehmen wir doch einfach mal Stan, der den Bogen zumacht. Hallo Stan. Ich lese hier an meinem Display Frage zum Thema mit Blick auf normalen Nutzer.
Also ich habe ein bisschen später zugeschalten und ich hätte ein ziemlich spannendes Thema heute. Und die große Frage, die ich hier stelle oder in die Diskussion mit Leuten komme, ist, spätestens dann, wenn man mit einem ganz normalen Nutzer zu tun hat, die sich nicht wirklich mit auskennen und eigentlich auch nicht auskennen wollen und eigentlich nur klicken wollen, dass einfach alles viel zu kompliziert ist. Und da war die Frage, die ich in eure Runde stellen wollte, ob ihr da Erfahrungen habt, wie ihr da vielleicht aus so einem euren Alltag in solchen Situationen damit umgeht.
Womit Erfahrungen haben, konkret?
Zum einen mit Technologien, die ich ein bisschen später zugeschalten habe, die wirklich einfach transparent sind für den normalen Nutzer. Ja, oder Verschleerung von Identitäten oder sowas. Also ich meine, die Realität ist ja schon, dass die Leute bei StudiVZ oder so ihre Daten mit Freude rausschmeißen. Und wie kriegt man das hin, dass man Leuten so ein Programm auf ihrem Windows Desktop oder sonst wo installiert und das funktioniert einfach und...
Ja, gar nicht, weil du bist gar nicht... Du hast gar nicht alles unter Kontrolle, was dritte auf dich, auf die Spur, auf dich... Dir auf die Spur...
Auf welche Weise dritte dir auf die Spur kommen stand.
Genau, allein schon deine IP-Adresse, mit der du nach außen sichtbar bist. Da gibt es dann die Möglichkeit, Dienste zu benutzen, wie zum Beispiel das Tor-Netzwerk, was hier schon mehrfach erwähnt wurde. Aber auch das ist alles nicht in dem einfachen Sinne out of the box und ohne Weiteres und ohne Kollateralschäden in deinem technischen Setup zu machen.
Also es ist halt so, dass man Spuren auf allen möglichen Netzwerkebenen oder Netzschichten hinterlässt. Das heißt, Tor hilft einem natürlich auch nur... Was rascht denn hier so?
Das ist dein Telefon irgendwie.
Also Tor hilft halt eben nur auf dem Netzwerk-Layer. Aber wenn man natürlich über Tor sich dann irgendwelche Google-Mails abruft oder halt über Cookies in seinem Browser wiederum eine individuelle Zuordnung durchgeführt wird, das heißt, es ist einfach so wie überall. Wenn man Dinge geheim halten will, genügt und es gibt irgendwie zehn mögliche Lacks, dann reicht eben ein Lack aus, um das Ganze aufliegen zu lassen. Man muss also eigentlich alle, also so viele Stellen wie möglich dicht machen. Für den normalen Nutzer im Moment keine Chance. Naja, es gibt erstaunlich viele Leute, die dann doch durchaus mit gewisser Energie, also wenn du dir anguckst, was teilweise über die Tor Notes auch läuft, die werden eben nicht nur von jetzt Nerds oder Hackern genutzt, sondern es gibt durchaus auch Leute, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer ein starkes Interesse daran haben, anonym aufzutreten. Und die kriegen das dann schon teilweise ganz gut raus.
Na gut, aber das war ja nicht deine ursprüngliche Frage. Sondern wie kann man es halt so mit, ich installiere mal eine Software und klick mache. Ich glaube, sowas gibt es nicht. Und vielleicht noch mal kurz als Ergänzung zu diesem Sache mit dem Tor. Also dieses Tor-Netzwerk ist ja ein Netzwerk. Tor steht für die Onien-Router. Da wird deine ganze Kommunikation in verschiedene Zwiebelschalen eingepackt mit verschiedenen Kryptografie-Übergängen, um eben einfach komplett zu vertuschen, woher du kommst. Das heißt, du wirst irgendwo mit deinen Daten irgendwo im Internet ausgespuckt, sodass derjenige, der von außen von der anderen Seite schaut, nur so dieses Tor-Netzwerk sieht und aber jetzt keine Ahnung hat, welches Datenpaket zu wem gehört. Auch sowas, was irgendwie schon mal so richtig wasserdicht klingt, lässt sich aushebeln. Auf dem letzten Kongress, den wir ja immer einmal im Jahr haben in Berlin, gab es einen Vortrag von jemanden, der herausgefunden, der sozusagen in der Lage war, indem er das Zeitverhalten der einzelnen Datenpakete, die aus so einem Tor-Netzwerk herauskamen, rauszufinden, an welchem Längen- und Breitengrad ein Computer steht, indem er einfach geschaut hat, wie die Zeitabweichung ist, die die Computer haben, in Abhängigkeit von der Tageszeit. Die Sonne geht auf und die Maschine wird wärmer und verhält sich einfach in der Zeit anders, als nachts wenn es kalt ist. Dann hast du im Prinzip schon mal genau die Tageszeit und nach der Länge des Tages, von Anfang bis Ende, kannst du dann auch noch den Breitengrad messen. Man muss einfach immer davon ausgehen, dass die Kommunikation im Prinzip sichtbar ist. Immer. Man darf niemals glauben, dass irgendein Tool, das ich mir jetzt installiert habe, da irgendwie weiterhilft. Das kann das verhindern oder verringern, aber nicht verhindern.
Also Dinge, also ich handhabe das auch als Dinge, von denen ich nun überhaupt nicht will, dass sie in irgendeiner Weise verbreitet werden. Die schreibt man auch am besten gar nicht auf, weder auf Papier noch in irgendeinem Computer, geschweige denn irgendwo in der Nähe des Internets. Und ja, manche Dinge bespricht man auch besser nicht am Telefon. Und da bringt das Internet zwar eine neue Qualität auch rein, aber grundsätzlich ja.
Das mit dem einen Programm war auch eher so als Beispiel. Mir ist klar, dass ich, also ich bin Informatiker, mir ist klar, dass ich so im Prinzip die Sachen, die ihr besprochen habt, das ist nur so ein Kongdommerrat aus verschiedensten Sachen, also E-Mail-Verschlüsselungen, Analyse-Dienste, den ganzen Kram. Aber ich komme wieder in eine Diskussion mit Leuten, wo dann so, ach, das ist jetzt kompliziert und naja. Also da war die Frage halt, Entschuldigung, da war die Frage, ob ihr da sozusagen wirklich optimistisch seid, dass ein Otto-Normalverbraucher vielleicht wirklich dein Bewusstsein für irgendwas kriegt, irgendwann kriegt, oder ob das immer nur in so einer Nische bleiben wird vor den Unwirk-Kreisen.
Ich glaube, doch früher oder später wird sich allein schon bei den Jugendlichen eine gewisse Kompetenz, so wie heute hoffentlich die Kinder beigebracht kriegen. Also geh nicht mit irgendwelchen Männern mit, die dir Bonbons oder Kuchen anbieten. Gut klappt leider nicht immer. So wird hoffentlich dann schon man mit vier oder fünf Jahren gesagt kriegen. Und wenn du hier in diesem Internet irgendwas machst, pass auf, also so handhabe ich das halt auch.
Ja, aber unsere Eltern haben uns auch gesagt, wir sollen nicht bei McDonalds essen gehen, weil es ungesund ist und wir gehen trotzdem hin. Ich glaube da nicht dran.
Andere Dinge, aber vielleicht so klar, also Dinge, die man vielleicht tun kann, auch als Normal User, ist beispielsweise, sich für bestimmte Aktivitäten, die man trennen will, also für berufliche und vielleicht bestimmte private Aktivitäten, sich vielleicht zwei Accounts auf dem Rechner anlegt. Also sich als zwei unterschiedliche Benutzer schon mal anmeldet. Das hilft schon mal ein wenig, bestimmte Auswirkungen oder bestimmte Dinge einfach zu vermeiden. Das ist, glaube ich, grundsätzlich...
Was ist der praktische Effekt davon, wenn ich auf meinem Rechner einmal Holgi 1 und einmal Holgi 2 bin?
Naja, wenn du zum Beispiel dann irgendwo die Präsentation hältst, dass nicht versehentlich irgendwie die Pornos aus deinem Cash irgendwo während der Firmepräsentation hochpoppen oder so. Das ist schon mal eine Geschichte. Ja, Tor wurde schon erwähnt und dann eventuell bestimmte Proxies oder auch bei den Browsereinstellungen kann man eine ganze Menge machen, um weniger Datenspuren zu hinterlassen. Aber erstmal, also der erste Schritt ist durchaus verschiedene Accounts für verschiedene Aktivitäten ist schon mal ein Ding, was dem einen oder anderen dann weiterhelfen könnte.
Boah, ich eben da die Erfahrung wirklich gemacht hab, also jetzt habe ich meine Freundin Account auf dem Rechner eingerichtet, weil ich mich damit auskenne, kann ich das an sie herantragen, kann ich das so einrichten, dass es für sie gut benutzbar ist. Aber das erfordert für mich relativ hohen Wartungsverband und ich glaube schon, dass mindestens zwei Accounts auf einem normalen Windows-Click-Rechner, das macht einfach niemand. Da kann man wahrscheinlich schon froh sein, wenn dann eine Firewall läuft.
Na, es gibt ja auch noch andere Betriebssysteme.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar, aber ich glaube in einer großen Masse ist das glaube ich ganz, ganz schwierig, dass das ihr so besprecht, was mir eben auch ein sehr wichtiges Anliegen ist, aber das sozusagen an die Leute ranzutragen und ihnen da ein Bewusstnis vermitteln, dass sie das auch verstehen, dass es vielleicht wieder mehr oft funktioniert.
Ich glaube das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist die Leute zu verunsichern. Also einfach ernsthaft zu beunruhigen, indem du Szenarien aufzeigst, die sie selbst in Bewegung setzen, so dass sie sich drauf schaffen, was sie denn alles tun können. Weil das natürlich auch von Fall zu Fall immer wieder ein bisschen andere Konfigurationen oder Ideen erfolgt.
Aber die Angst weicht in dem Moment, wo die Porno-Seite oben ist. Wenn die Leute etwas vor der Nase haben, was sie jetzt wirklich haben wollen, dann wird das einfach alles soweit ignoriert. Ich glaube nicht, dass man mit Angst da ausreichend arbeiten kann. Man muss sich einfach auch darüber klar werden, was es eben bedeutet, eine digitale Identität zu haben. Und die hat man ab dem Moment, wo man anfängt, in ein Webbrowser irgendwas einzugeben. Und das ist auch etwas, wo ich eigentlich eben noch mal draufholde, jetzt sind wir mit der Sendung auch schon fast durch, vielleicht das noch mal so ein bisschen zum Abschluss. Viele Leute sind sich nicht des Wertes bewusst, den eine Anonymität oder auch nur eine Pseudonymität für sie bedeuten kann. Und in der öffentlichen Diskussion derzeit geht es immer so in Richtung wo alle müssen sich ausweisen, alle müssen sich registrieren, wir müssen sie alle erfassen, wir müssen alle in Daten banken und wir müssen die Missetäter in die Zeitungen abdrucken und so weiter, damit es uns besser geht und damit wir sicherer leben können. Ich glaube aber, das ist der totale Holzweg.
Na gut, und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat ja heute, oder gestern mit dem Cicero-Urteil der Anonymität und dem Informantenschutz speziell im Bereich Presse doch mal wieder einen hohen Stellenwert eingeräumt.
Ja, aber es ist schade, dass es immer erst das Bundesverfassungsgericht kommen muss, um solche grundlegenden Einsichten zu haben. Das muss halt einfach in die Köppe rein.
Vor allem, wenn man die Verfassung geändert hat, kann das auch nicht mehr kommen.
Damit wir das nicht unerwähnt gelassen haben, diese Mikado-Geschichte. Da gab es jetzt wieder diesen Fall, so wir müssen ja was gegen Kinderpornografie tun. Da ist ja auch grundsätzlich erst mal nichts gegen einzuwenden. Und dann gab es da halt so eine Site und da wurde halt irgendwie Material eben verdient und offensichtlich auch gekauft. Und die ganzen Ermittlungen, Ermittlungen, Strafermitteln, sollten ja erst mal sozusagen versuchen, irgendwelche Missetäter zu finden. Die haben sie aber dann nicht rausbekommen. Und dann standen sie irgendwie da vor dieser Webseite und wussten nicht so richtig, wie sie da rankommen sollten. Und dann ist ihnen das eingefallen, naja, dann gehen wir doch irgendwie auf die Käufer zu. Und haben das sozusagen jetzt als großen Fall dargestellt, dass sie eben die Leute, die da jetzt Content gekauft haben, dass sie denen hinterhergehen. Was haben sie dann gemacht? Wir erzählen mal die kurze Geschichte. Da sie selber die Befugnisse noch gar nicht haben, haben sie sich was mauschliges ausgedacht und sind dann einfach auf die Kreditkartenunternehmen zugegangen. Und so, ah ja, bin ich da reinzufällig.
Auf die Banken.
Genau, auf die Banken. Also genau, nicht die Kreditkartenunternehmen, sondern die Unternehmen, sprich die Banken, die für diese Kreditkartenunternehmen die eigentlichen Transaktionen durchführen. Nach dem Motto, ja, guckt doch mal in euren Datenbeständen nach diesem und jedem, wenn ihr da was findet.
Nach diesem Betrag.
Genau, mit so fünf verschiedene Sachen, Betrag und Herkunft und Target und so weiter. So, dann sind da irgendwie 20 Leute bei rausgefallen oder so.
Mehr, paar hundert.
Paar hundert, okay. Und denen sind sie dann irgendwie aufs Dach gestiegen. Einer davon war wohl ganz offensichtlich total unschuldig. Und da sind dann die Bullen irgendwie aufgelaufen kurz vor Weihnachten und wollten ihnen dann mal so seine Rechner beschlagen haben.
Und das waren mittelständische Unternehmen.
Genau so, der sah jetzt irgendwie gerade mal so seinen Jahresumsatz irgendwie da hinsichtlich. Konnte sich nur noch retten, weil er sich irgendwie vage daran erinnern konnte, dass irgendwie er vor ein, zwei Jahren da mal irgendwas war mit irgendeiner Abbuchung.
Gegen die er widersprochen hatte damals. Und damit konnte er gerade noch eben die Beschlagnahme der Rechner und mit Hilfe seines Anwalts verhindern. Aber das war halt schon sehr knapp. Dazu kommt noch vielleicht ein Ding, dass es überhaupt ein komplettes Unding war, eine absolute Schweinerei, solche Dinge von den Banken erledigen zu lassen. Weil wer sagt denn zum Beispiel, dass die Banken nicht vorher die Liste, die sie an die Polizei weitergereicht haben, dann von eigenen Kunden und eigenen Mitarbeitern gesäubert haben?
Das ist ein totales Unding. Aber ich hab jetzt auch Anonymität und diesen Vorfall ein bisschen zusammen geworfen, um einfach nur eins zu sagen. Man hat nicht alles unter Kontrolle. Und in dem Moment, wo mehr Daten erfasst werden, wird einfach der Missbrauch ganz automatisch größer werden.
Und es passieren mehr Fehler.
Genau, es passieren mehr Fehler. Auch wenn tausend Politiker und Amtsschimmel und Polizisten immer wieder behaupten, sie würden ja nur es da und da und dafür verwenden. Es ist alles Quatsch. Man muss sich nur die letzten zehn Jahre Autobahn-Mautgeschichte anschauen. Alles, was vorhergesagt wurde, ist genauso passiert. Und demnächst haben wir vielleicht wirklich nochmal die Fußgänger.
Und die Politiker sind sich auch in solchen Dingen dann nicht zu schade, einem wirklich die Hucke voll zu lügen und ein Jahr später sich nicht mehr dran zu erinnern, was hier gesagt wurde.
Das war Chaosradio 121. Digitale Identitäten waren unser Thema. Im Studio waren Pavel, Tim und Holgi. Chaosradio 122 gibt es am 28. März 2007. Und jetzt gibt es den Nightfly mit Martin Petersdorf. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit und gute Nacht.
Und wer sich das alles nochmal anhören soll, der kann das auch tun, weil Chaosradio gibt es ja auch als Podcast.